for call of duty black ops 2 Activision
is going black to the future in this
latest entry of the world devouring
shooter series you are thrown into the
year twenty twenty-five and have to
contend with terrorists who have some
seriously high-tech weaponry we sat down
with Mark Lamia head of the design
studio treyarch to find out why this
year's Call of Duty is different than
all the rest so if you're a call of duty
player you're gonna be really excited
about black ops 2 there's a ton of new
gameplay in store for you starting with
the story itself we have story branching
which means the choices that you make in
the campaign are going to have an effect
on your story arc these new missions
called strike force levels which have
you played call of duty before totally
new those missions themselves there's
sandbox levels you're gonna be able to
take over anything on the battlefield
totally new experience the setting is is
new not only does it take place in 20-25
it's a generation spanning fiction it
takes place in 20-25 but as part of the
story as we're telling you about the
villain you're going to be going back in
time through the eyes of woods who's
going to tell you about where and how
you and your father alex mason met this
film for the first time and it's in the
late 80s during the Cold War so strike
first levels are a totally new concept
call of duty one of the critical design
goals when we were coming up with this
mode was that it'd be accessible but
have depth and allow for replayability
and so it does introduce non-linearity
the campaign structure because what'll
happen is as the Cold War is playing out
in the year twenty twenty-five what will
happen is they'll be these proxy wars
and and these hot spots you'll be
introduced to them by JSOC and asked to
pick which one of these hot spots you
want to take on that's choice of levels
inside of the campaign when you play
these you can either succeed or fail and
if you succeed or fail it sets the story
arc of the Cold War in 20-25 on a
different trajectory the approach on
multiplayer is similar to how we're
approaching our campaign and that is
that we're taking a good hard look at
at our multiplayer mode and nothing is
being held sacred our community gives us
a ton of feedback and we're melding that
with with our own design goals and
aspirations and I think we're coming up
with a an awesome unique multiplayer
that people haven't had as long as
people having a good time playing call
of duty games I think inside the
franchise that's a big win for everybody